okay so let's zoom out for a moment okay
so this is just kind of a subtopic that
we've been in but as I've been saying
you know this is part it's much bigger
hole and there are lots of ideas that
we've been looking at which feed into
this and they're going to help you have
context for how this is different to
physics ok so in mathematics for
instance as a topic before we looked at
calculus there was a kind of function
that we looked at which fed into natural
growth and decay what kinds of functions
will be looking at exponential functions
right which of course Exponential's and
logs there are really two sides of the
same coin so we understood them as their
own and topic and then we said ok well
let's now have a think about a
particular physical example of goods and
that was natural growth in decay okay in
rate of change we did a similar kind of
thing we met the idea of broadly
speaking algebraic functions we've been
working with these four years basically
since we learnt what algebra was we
learn what algebraic functions were and
that's where we understood rates of
change and we're going to look at those
ideas again when we try and relate
together displacement and velocity and
acceleration ok little sorry yes yep
when we have a think about all the other
topics i want you to contemplate for a
second which are the topics I've been
related to the kinds of ideas will be
looking at at the moment in particular
in rates of change I said ok so we've
got calculus is already what our pink
sort of you know you've got calculus in
the physical world ok and there are two
main things that are still sort of left
off which are going to be looked at
which we've already looked at and we're
going to look at the third I think I
think that a bit what is your vacuum the
first one is remember we looking at
rates of change I talked about objects
and there are of particular shapes right
so for example you might have a
spherical balloon that's inflating or
you have like am a trough of water which
is like a triangular prism and the shape
of what you're dealing with completely
defines your rate of change ok so
obviously geometry which is a huge field
a huge area of matts before we even got
to calculus that kind of fed into this
and it's also going to feed into this
how the objects move I fails as one last
idea which is going to feed in which we
need for this which is tree nama tree
and tree and on tree I suppose you can
think of in its connection to geometry
but most importantly it's going to be
very important when we understand number
one these masses and forces but also
because tree node tree is about you know
it's about something like this right
like this is where it's all born from
yeah x1 what you'll find is whenever
you've got an object and it's moving in
a particular direction okay any object
that's moving in a particular direction
if it's moving in something more
complicated than just like up and down
or left and right there's some
combination of different things together
your you're trying to say okay look
there's a there's a twirl that's much
too thick there's going to be a
component that goes in one direction and
another one that goes perpendicular and
it's some combination of those will give
you the direction that you're talking
about okay so anytime you're trying to
resolve different directions and
resolves actually the important word
whether it's a you know up down left
right which is projectile motion or
you're going round and round in a circle
which is what all located circular
motion trigonometry is involved okay so
these are going to be their pieces
outside of calculus that feed into
calculus in the physical world and help
us understand motion okay now last them
I've left this to last because people
say to me ah this is frustrating because
this is why I didn't study physics I
didn't study physics with other at
school and so I found myself very very
confused because there's this huge
amount of overlap over here but physics
is completely dear friend it's a reason
why it's it's own subject and I want to
try to explain why so firstly there's a
difference in content there's a
difference in the focus right so physics
entrant is interested in a whole bunch
of things that the mathematics of motion
is not interested for example this word
kinematics right you might think are
there's a relationship ship there to
kinetic right which is true kinetic
energy energy potential energy these are
very important ideas in physics but they
don't really have that all that much
relevance
to when we look at the mathematics of
motion okay in the same way you'll have
objects that are moving and you it
really matters what those objects are
made of in physics right and the
question of matter is kind of
fundamental to what physics is but in in
motion in mathematics we don't care what
it's made of we are interested in how to
move it and why it's doing that okay
what forces are influenced you yeah ah
no no not really I mean you can consider
yeah so you can't consider that but you
see I don't need to know an object's I
no need to understand comprehensively
and objects density in order to
understand the medium around it and how
heavy it is right that's all that's
interested that's all I'm interesting
okay one last idea that really matters
in physics that are in motion we don't
really worry about which is space now I
don't mean space as in like astronomy
space and i don't mean space as in like
geometric space I me like spaces in
space-time ok now the nature of space in
space-time is something that obviously
very important physics and we're not
worried about emotion see you can see
despite the huge overlap these are very
different bits now there's one thing
that I've left off you notice this green
thing up here in the corner which I've
sort of dotted because it's kind of
point to us not that much because it's
sort of in the background that's the
question of how do you know how do you
work things out in this field right and
we call this epistemology it's the study
of how you know things right now anyone
who's had any thinking about philosophy
or even in English you'll have a thing
you are you understand epistemological
frameworks is the way we say it okay how
do you know something is true in physics
versus in mathematics or physics is a
science right it's an experimental
science so the way you know things is
you try them out you do them over and
over again and you make observations
that's the way things work in physics
that's how we know things it is that's
why we build
large hadron colliders underneath the
ground that's our input telescopes in
space because we need to see these
things we need to understand what's
going on okay now remember i said to you
are these this is kind of a broad
oversimplification obviously in
mathematics we experiment as well we try
things out we have plot the size we see
okay we have an idea can we test it out
can we see whether it works or not but
fundamentally like the DNA of
mathematics is not about experimentation
of the observation you can't prove
something by exhaustion of mathematics
that's no proof i don't care if you've
seen it a billion times i only need to
find one contradiction and the whole
thing force to pieces mathematics
reasons things out and a knows things
differently we use logic and argument
that's how we know things all you need
is imagination to be a mathematician no
apparatus required you just need this
and this and off you go